I assure you brother The Sun will shine
on us again your optimism is misplaced
has gone well for one thing I'm north
Asgardian and for another hey everybody
it's Charlie the Sun will shine on us
again brother
and it's now confirmed because variety
just posted a report that Marvel is
developing spin-off TV shows for Loki
Scarlet Witch in the other Avengers
level characters that have not gotten
their own solo movies yet so time to
freak out we got to break this down
because this is such awesome news
there's a new round of that spider-man
ps4 giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video I'll name a new winner at
the end of this important stuff first
right now they're naming Scarlet Witch
and Loki as the first two characters and
the way they're billing this is that
it's going to be an anthology series of
sorts like six to eight episodes of a TV
series on their new Disney streaming
service Tom Hiddleston and elizabeth
Olsen would be coming back to play their
characters and it would just be a way to
tell more story with characters like say
The Hulk or Hawkeye people that haven't
gotten their own dedicated trilogy of
movies like Thor is probably gonna get a
fourth movie at some point so he's
getting plenty of movies Iron Man got a
trilogy he's featured prominently in all
the Avengers films even Black Widow is
getting her own film series but there
are so many good characters that we've
seen since phase one that haven't gotten
that limelight so they're just using
this as an opportunity to make up for
that the way variety is reporting about
the production of these series is the
Disney's intending on spending buckets
of money so think about HBO spending say
10 million dollars an episode on Game of
Thrones or Westworld
imagine Marvel doing something like that
with the 6 to 8 episode anthology series
focusing on Loki then focusing on
Scarlet Witch then focusing on other
characters they haven't said how many
seasons they have the actors locked down
for like if Tom Hiddleston would only be
around for the first season and it would
be like a Loki tales of Asgard situation
then they would go to Scarlet Witch set
during a different time period and Loki
would not be involved with that or if
everybody's gonna be crossing over but
this is the shared universe with the
movies that people have been asking for
for TV series like ages a shield
technically connected to the
movies but very little crossover
upstream downstream like the movie
characters don't appear on the TV shows
the TV characters don't appear in the
movies it sounds like Disney's using
their new streaming service to correct
that because you would literally have
the movie actors playing their
characters during the TV series they
didn't say exactly what the story would
be my assumption is is that it's gonna
be set during a different time period
because Loki is supposed to be dead as
the end of infinity war even though a
different version of Loki is gonna be
featured during Avengers 4 even though
Scarlet Witch has been turned to ash I
believe she's coming back I wouldn't be
surprised if visions showed up during
her TV series but that would also
probably be set during a different time
period maybe sometime in between the
movies in terms of moving the story
forward I think Scarlet Witch is a
better candidate for that because I
think that they'll bring her back and I
don't it that they're gonna roll back
Loki being dead he'll be stuck in
Valhalla
and find some other way to come back
when characters like Loki and Thor have
been alive for 1500 plus years is a lot
easier to do something said in the past
that it is for someone like scarlet
witch who ages in normal time like the
rest of us I've always wanted them to do
a tales of Asgard series say like Game
of Thrones Marvel's Game of Thrones and
it would be like Odin's conquest of the
nine realms like we got a teaser for
that during Ragnarok it was very bloody
hella will be the protagonist of that a
violent appetites rule beyond my control
couldn't stop it so I'm prisons huh
knocks away
she Joseph strength mascot and once she
gets there a puzzle will be variety
didn't report any specifics about other
Thor characters showing up like Chris
Hemsworth or Anthony Hopkins coming back
as Odin or Cate Blanchet coming back as
hella so I think that's all up in the
air right now and it's gonna be a little
while before Disney says exactly what
the story is going to be but clearly
they've been working on something like
this since they wanted to launch their
streaming service so that is the killer
programming that they need like you want
that big Avengers content you have to
get our streaming service so that would
definitely make me sign up for that
people have been asking for a Hawkeye
Netflix series ever since they launched
the Netflix TV shows well now they can
actually do that and for the most part I
think most of these characters will be
back in Avengers 4 so most of these TV
series can deal with what happens with
the characters next but that doesn't
necessarily mean that you have to do is
set in the future it could always be set
in the past but I think part of the idea
is part of the beauty is is that you can
do a connected TV universe within this
Disney streaming service DC is kind of
doing the same thing with their
streaming service that they just
launched while all the shows are
connected but they're not necessarily
connected to all the other TV shows that
are happening because Disney is pulling
away from Netflix I don't know what that
means for the potential of Netflix
characters crossing over to these Disney
streaming shows like Loki or Scarlet
Witch but there's not a big connection
between those characters so I'm not
expecting it it'd be more likely that
you'd have Coulson or somebody else show
up somebody that has history with say
Loki but that just depends on when it's
set during the time line you have to
remember to the characters like Loki
don't spend a lot of time on earth in
their 1500 year history he traveled all
over the galaxy so I think the beauty of
a series like that is that you could do
something set in outer space where he
just hops around but mischief managed
this is such an awesome news break I
would have never thought that they would
have done something like this didn't see
that's coming people have been asking
Kevin Feige about movie actors popping
up on TV shows for years now in the last
really telling answer that he gave is
that he expected at some point there
would be duplication but what he meant
by that is the expected at some point
there would be a TV show that would do a
version of a movie character not
necessarily that all the movie actors
would come on the TV shows reprising
their characters but this just
completely throws that out of the water
and he gave that answer before they
announced the Disney streaming service I
think the executives at Disney realized
that if they spent the right amount of
money had the right creative and got the
movie actors to come back that would get
people to pay for this new service they
haven't announced a pricing model or
anything like that that'll probably
happen sometime next year the service is
supposed to launch at the end of 2019 so
it's still a long ways off they'll
probably have more announcements about
it at Comic Con next year but for those
of you that have been wanting a Hulk
movie for a long time this is how they
sidestep that distribution issues that
they have with Universal I want to just
make one thing perfectly clear
a standalone Hulk movie will never
happen because Universal has the rights
to the standalone Hulk movie and for
some reason they don't know how to play
well with Marvel and they don't want to
make money and with you as the new Hulk
it would be terrible like people ask
Mark Ruffalo why don't you make a Hulk
film and he's like well Universal still
has the distribution rights and
apparently they don't want to make any
money because they didn't see reason the
way that the Sony people did with the
spider-man sharing arrangement so when
he says it's never gonna happen
technically a movie with the Hulk might
never happen but a TV series now is
totally doable they do have the rights
to do that the other thing that we
should say too is is that just because a
couple big characters might die during
Avengers 4 and not come back in the
movies that also doesn't mean that they
couldn't appear in any of these TV
series because remember don't know
exactly when they're gonna be set in the
timeline not all of them might be set in
the future if you do something in the
past Chris Evans who's on my death
predictions list could totally come back
for something set in the past but
remember the whole idea is is these are
supposed to focus on characters that
have not gotten a lot of big movies so
that's why they're starting with Loki in
Scarlet Witch because they're really
popular characters but they just haven't
found the right mixture to give them
their own solo movie the funny thing
about this is I've been getting a lot of
requests from a couple people persistent
that I do Scarlet Witch content what do
you think is gonna happen to her well
now we know she's gonna get her own TV
series so just post all your reactions
in the comments below let me know what
you want them to do for the stories for
these TV series Ashton Jackson
congratulations you're the giveaway
winner for my last big video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details click here to
rewatch the Captain Marvel trailer a
billion more times and click here for my
last big Loki video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]